It's been a wild year in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, with TV shows like "WandaVision,"
"Loki," and "What If...?" paving the way for
the Multiverse to crack reality wide open
in "Spider-Man: No Way Home" and "Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness." Although the
intention is to introduce alternate versions of
classic heroes and villains, there are tragic
stories at the heart of these grand adventures --
and the "Doctor Strange" sequel is no different.
The film sees the Scarlet Witch struggling to
cope after losing her children in "WandaVision"
and desperately wanting to find another
universe where she can be with them.
In doing so, she dabbles in dark magic
while hunting the superpowered America
Chavez, [CHA-vez] who has the ability
to punch her way between universes.
Thankfully, the young hero has
Doctor Strange to protect her,
and their journey across the Multiverse takes
them to some wildly different universes.
Although most of their time is spent on Earth-838,
[eight three eight] which is where they meet
Professor X [ECKS], the rest of the Illuminati,
and a variant of Christine Palmer, they first
tumble through several other realities -- each
with its own unique visual style -- including a
prehistoric world, an underwater universe, and
even one where they're made entirely of paint.
But the scene also hides a surprising
blink-and-you'll-miss-it "Spider-Man" Easter egg.
Although Strange briefly name-drops Spider-Man
when discussing his experience with the
Multiverse, the film doesn't really address
the events of "Spider-Man: No Way Home."
No, don't worry -- you didn't miss
a sneaky cameo from Tom Holland,
Tobey Maguire, or Andrew Garfield. Instead,
there's a surprising Easter egg in a sleek,
futuristic universe that shows up midway through
that psychedelic leap through alternate realities.
It's not exactly clear where they are within
that version of Earth, but it looks highly
advanced -- almost to the point where it has an
industrial feel to it. On the left-hand side of
the screen, a drone flies past the two Multiversal
travelers -- and it has the exact same design as
the Stark Industries drones used by Peter Parker
and Mysterio in "Spider-Man: Far from Home."
The drones play a key part in Spidey's MCU
story because after Tony Stark's death, he
passes Peter the keys to artificial intelligence
called EDITH, which also grants him access to
satellite weapons and an army of drones. And
although Peter had learned to become a more
responsible hero since "Spider-Man: Homecoming"
and even becomes an Avenger in "Avengers:
Infinity War," Tony clearly wasn't thinking when
he decided to give a teenager that sort of power.
Anyway, these drones ultimately cause chaos
and destruction at the hands of Mysterio,
even killing Mysterio himself. As we all know,
the villain posthumously leaks Peter's identity
to the world while blaming him for his death.
So it's a little surprising that one of the
universes shows the drone flying around a
futuristic world. What does it all mean?
We'll try not to get too excited here, but a
"Spider-Man" Easter egg in a futuristic setting
instantly makes us think of "Spider-Man
2099." As you may have guessed, his story
is set at the end of the century, long after the
Avengers of old have all died or disappeared and
New York has become a dystopian nightmare
that wouldn't look out of place in "Blade
Runner." Built on the ruins of the old city,
the bustling metropolis is called Nueva York,
and it is home to an incredibly powerful sinister
corporation called Alchemax [AL-kuh-MAX]. Miguel
O'Hara [muh-GEL O-HAIR-uh] , a
geneticist working at the company,
winds up having his genes rewritten with
a spider's DNA by accident -- and quickly
suits up as Spider-Man 2099 to fight the
injustices committed by his own employer.
Now, the reference in "Multiverse of Madness"
probably means nothing in the grand scheme of
things -- it's just an inventive look at another
universe that uses familiar imagery for fans to
recognize -- but it would be very, very cool to
see Spider-Man 2099 in live action. Thankfully,
the futuristic web-slinger is already heading to
the big screen in 2023's "Spider-Man: Across the
Spider-Verse" -- and Oscar Isaac is reprising the
role after voicing him in the post-credits scene
of "Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse."
But this sequence is another reason why
"Multiverse of Madness" is so refreshing: It
allows Marvel to really get creative with its
visuals and its storytelling rather than sticking
to its often generic-looking action scenes.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don’t miss a single one.